the Naga chili is super hot on this
Scoville scale I think it's like over a
million that's like kind of equivalent
to Ghost Pepper yeah yeah um going be
okay so give me a look right now let's
go this is really
spicy oh
my so I'm looking at this one yeah hey
guys this episode is a special one
because we're in my home state if you
didn't know I'm a Jersey girl at heart
we're in the heart of Jersey City India
square also known as Little India and
it's a beautiful neighborhood lots of
colors smells spices and we're exploring
all things South Asian Spice when it
comes to South Asian Spice there is a
lot of ground to cover today's food call
is just the very tip of the iceberg so
today I'm meeting up with my friend Jeff
Sola elwa we're going to eat one of her
favorite foods dosas at the Dosa house
right over there actually then Sol and I
will meet up with our friend food writer
priia Krishna to go to Kai kitchen
featuring Homestyle Bangladeshi dishes
super excited for it cuz it's my first
time trying it but before I meet up with
them I'm going to get my palette a
little wet start off with a little snack
and we're going to go try some Indian
Street Food Pony purri let's
go some ponti purri this is something
that I'm pretty familiar with uh a good
friend of mine loves to make this and
she always like pops it in everyone's
mouth and which is really fun I'm very
excited because I haven't had it for a
while here we
go look it's so cute in here because
this is traditional Indian Street Food
snack I think they kind of made it feel
like that indoors which is really fun
hello how are you potato chickpeas
potato or chickpeas okay let's try the
potato spicy yeah it's spicy spicy okay
uh and what's the different uh purri
[Music]
mint okay just okay just like that all
right I think the trick is that you have
to eat it in one bite as fast as you can
so that it doesn't break but this this
is
huge one
[Music]
more that was spicy spicy which one is
the spiciest ginger garlic spicy cuz
that Mint one was pretty it was pretty
spicy see there's different pones which
is spice water can I try the um the
garlic all right okay I I am a garlic
girl as well and garlic and chilies is
like match made in heaven for me
so M I like the
garlic I really like the the garlic one
is like super yummy actually it's pretty
hot my mouth is starting to water thank
you so
much
[Music]
hey Sola In the Flesh good to see you
good to see you I'm so excited to eat
some TOA I know that's like your
favorite thing ever it is one one of my
favorite food one of your favorite foods
yes I wrote there's too many you can't
it's like your children you can't pick
one you go after you oh thank you so
what's special about ad DOA exactly it's
a fermented batter yeah so it's um rice
and lentil Blended and fermented with a
little bit of fener and then it gets
like a Sourdough kind of Tang okay and
you can adjust how like crispy or soft
it is by playing with the ratio of rice
to lentil what makes it crispy is it the
rice it's the rice it's the rice okay so
the lentils make it
more okay what are we ordering what's
the spiciest one the spiciest spicy
and let's do the karami onion onion
onion masala dosa and then uh paper
Masala DOA one paper Masala and then we
need the drinks lety Lusty yeah yeah
yeah all right yeah yeah that sounds
good okay how about your Dosa eating
skills though do eating skills yeah I
can eat yeah Dosa is not something my
mom made at home okay we'd always go out
for it cuz it is more Indian and we're
Bangladeshi okay um but it was one of my
like favorite foods so whenever we had
to go buy Indian clothes right which was
something I hated so itchy so to bribe
me to put up with it we'd have a Dosa
first so that's your memory tied with
Dosa briberry
briberry oh my God see isn't that
exciting for a child oh that is very
exciting for here we go how do they how
do they have a griddle this big it's the
whole damn thing right that's insane
like we just have to do
this you got to get in it while it's hot
okay show me how it's done you just tear
so crispy are you you can smell the Tang
you can smell the fermented like
sourdough Vibes and then just rip and
dip this is coconut this is the Tomato
the fermented notes of like the sour is
like very addicting it makes you want to
keep going back for more and that
texture is awesome I like to break up in
the middle what it stuffed okay so you
can access the stuffing mhm I like to
then take from the end and grab some of
my stuffing okay this is Sol's way of
eating and then dip okay so it is like a
very traditional indigenous food to
South India but now you see it
throughout South Asia and um nowadays
what a DOA is is like pretty specific
it's always rice and lentils that are
Blended and fermented together but the
traditional one it was any combo of
grain and pulse people get crazy these
days people get crazy like what I like
to make pizza with it you like to make
pizza with this pizza Dosa Dosa Pizza
like if you stuff it with cheese and
yeah yeah do the oh my God this a spicy
oh this one's a spicy one the heat has
come for us oh my God it smells so good
I love onion so this one is the spicy
one wo that was really spicy whatever I
ate right now it looks like there's
green chilies and green onion and cumin
in the batter and it's like all kind of
got caramelized and we still have that
potato filling in the middle
yeah I'm really into it and this is so
fun to eat no wonder you're you were
like loving this as a kid I mean you say
that your heat tolerance is bad but like
you're fine I was really scared cuz this
is the channel That does hot ones so
like I didn't know how bad this was
going to get you're a heat eater oh my
goodness did we order three I guess so
all right which one is this is it a
different this one's gunpowder I love
this actually this is my favorite DOA
okay this is the favorite one you sure
yes yes so cuz you said that for every
single thing that came maybe I just like
them all you put the dose of batter out
on The Griddle it's only cooked on one
side for the batter fully cooked you
sprinkle this stuff on that's called
gunpowder spice what is this gunpowder
spice it's called gunpowder cuz it's so
freaking hot got it but I thought you
don't like spicy I love this there's
actually a recipe for it in my book buy
it
today buy let's B bu the gum powder
recipe it's ground up mixture of chilies
uh nuts coconut lentils it's like a dry
Chutney so often times folks will mix it
with mustard oil and dunk things into it
to like even level up that heat okay
even more and then I love it in Dosa so
it's sprinkled on top it's like a
mixture of salty sweet spicy and a lot
of umami
okay you can taste the roasted peanut m
in there yeah it's a totally different
flavor profile mhm and there is heat but
the heat in a different way than the
Chili's mhm it's like the dried spice
and I taste the coconut like very
strongly I love it yeah wow oh that is
delicious I mean it's it's pretty spicy
oh I just got it in my nose this one is
like the dried chili heat that I feel
like hits your nose more and then the
green chili heat is more like in the
back of your throat yeah definitely
going down yeah very very different
spices but spice level wise is the same
my mouth is you know you know pretty
tingly right now it's burning I'm fine
you're F she's like just saying for some
people this will definitely be like
pretty spicy yeah and it's it's about
balance like you don't eat a meal of all
spicy things you get like a bite from
the onion and a bite from the mustard
but it's mellowed out by the potato it's
balanced it's balanced all right so this
was amazing thank you so much for
showing me the world of Dosa next up
we're going to meet up with priia who is
your good friend as well and we're going
to goat eat at Karai kitchen we's go for
a walk digest this a bit I know I'll
this to go and I'll eat ity
[Music]
later ready for the next round oh yes I
am yeah hi fre hi how is Dosa it was
very good yeah how are
you I'm so excited for this have you
ever had Bangladeshi food I have not so
why why karaya kitchen it is one of the
city's only Bangladeshi restaurants I
feel like you can attest it's really
hard to find Bangladeshi food in
restaurants even though it's
bangladeshis run a lot of Indian
restaurants yes it's very strange they
all run restaurants but they only make
chicken SE Masala yeah not here but here
is Bangladeshi people making Bangladeshi
food which is a
[Music]
rarity hi
hi we're so that you're here welcome
welcome thank you so much for having us
thank you we're so excited hi Mom hello
welcome hey thanks for having us we are
so excited to feed you we hope you're
hungry so what do we have on the menu
today traditionally Bishi food we like
to eat in courses and we got some spicy
dishes too so so so many courses many
courses yes I'm curious how does it
differ from other South Asian that's
really difficult to answer because the
food of Bangladesh is hyper Regional so
my mom is from taka the capital the
other part is from bogra which is a
little bit more North generally there
are some similarities some things that
you'll always see so Bangladesh is known
as the land of rivers so of course you
know Seafood is fish is a big part of
the diet it's a Muslim country so you
won't see pork but you will see beef and
then certain things you know we love
like our mustard oil and mustard seeds
so you kind of just have to eat it like
you have to try it and you have have to
try it you can uh feel the difference
The Taste is different um there's
silverware but of course we eat with our
hands anything goes here whatever you're
comfortable with we can go do it I feel
like it doesn't taste right if you don't
eat with your hand you have to mix it
all together we actually don't adjust
spice levels on anything if it's meant
to be spicy it's going to be spicy if
it's meant to be mild it's going to be
mild um so the Bas there's four these
are the mashes that's the beun paraa the
eggplant mash the aloa the potato mash
that's a mishumaa which I guess is like
a sweet pumpkin and that's a shi baa
it's fermented fish the Naga chili is
something that you'll see in Bangladeshi
Cuisine and it's super hot on this goal
scale I think it's like over a million
that's like kind of equivalent ghost
pepper yeah yeah
um give me a look right now but not
again like not all Bas are that spicy
after you do the Bas of course we have
seafood mustard Hils over there Hils is
the National fish of Bangladesh we do
also have chingri Doza which is a shrimp
dopiaza right over there there's V down
there so that's the egg with um chili
tomato onion uh we have the coconut milk
chicken um that's one of my favorites
yummy we have beef um it's like a kosha
right like a style it's like a dry or
bua all right enjoy thank you so much
thank you this looks amazing okay you
got to get the right first you guys got
to walk me through this the center of
the plate my parents said it's bad luck
to have less than two scoops of rice
okay I really don't want bad luck so put
the Bas around so you kind of like mix
the rice in with the p you want to start
with and make something called a LMA
which is like a mouthful it's almost
like you're making a tiny little rice
ball the key to eating with your hands
is you don't get it on your fingers you
stay on your fingertips and then use
your thumb to push it in okay all right
let me all right
[Music]
I'm really bad at eating with my hands
but really Smokey really Smokey really
good okay I'm going to go
for okay potato it's not that bad
manageable yeah I feel like it's a sign
of good cooking when it has the spice
but the spice the heat does not like
take over the entire dish and you can
taste the other elements it's potato
first and then you get chili after and
it's fully building it builds yeah I was
like I'm surprised okay with it B of it
yeah so explain to me the difference
between spicy and spices I feel like
spices are flavors all different kinds
not necessarily hot you know it could be
aromatic or nutty or citrusy they all
compliment each other CU like each of
the even each of the chilies has a
specific flavor my mom is really
particular when she cooks about what
kind of heat she's adding is she adding
gush red chili powder is she adding
dried red chilies is she adding hurry
merch or fresh cre chilies which are a
little fruer mhm every type sort of
gives you a little bit of a different
flavor and compliments the spices in a
different way okay these are the
vegetables there's whole green chilies
thank
[Music]
you oh this is this has quite a lot of
heat the
veggies maybe you just bit into a green
chili okay okay maybe maybe that's what
it is need to wash our hands really
thoroughly before removing our contact
lenses made that mistake before my is
already starting to run but I could use
more spice we should try the fish you
need a little bit rice I know I know
thank you mustard oil has this like it's
like this astringent like sinus clearing
sinus clearing yeah that I love it's so
fish and mustard oil to me is like a
match made in heaven this is so good the
sauce the mustard oil is so I just I
love mustard oil oh my god when you cook
it it sort of tempers that burning
effect but you still get the sinus
clearing little bit Yeah Wasabi esque
since there's so much fat in the fish is
that Mellows it all out totally and it
makes it just really Savory cuz the fish
is so Savory this is so good the sauce
is like everything though it's so so so
so good D this is a green chili
yes I guess it's kind spicy yeah I mean
it has sort of the same intensity as a
tii chili yeah mhm yeah mhm the thing
with the green chilies is my mom would
do different things with it like
depending on how much heat you want
versus flavor like sometimes like here
they're whole and the stem is removed so
then you just get the aroma and then if
she wants to level up the heat she'll
slit it in half and then you get a
little bit of heat and then mostly still
flavor and then when you really want to
just like kill somebody you chop it up
mhm and it kind of like balances all
like the mustard like the warming spices
and it actually makes my mouth water
more and it's just like like making like
me salivate this is sort of what chilies
are supposed to do like yes they're
spicy but they also compliment they also
add something it's not that hot maybe
I'm okay we're going to have that
tumeric glow what are you guys up to
what's what's the next project oh please
go buy my book I have a baby to feed now
both of you have books Sol has an
amazing book called start here Sol is
one of the best cooks that I know I'm
very excited to buy her book are we
doing this like plugging each other wait
is your children's book out my
children's book is out um next April but
I have a book you're writing a
children's book I love that yes it's
sort of a little sister to my cookbook
indian-ish which is about Indian food
which I think they have at this
restaurant we have oh my God show it we
did an event with Pria before the
pandemic so we keep this copy of uh
Indian here look at all these beautiful
recipes we've got it right here
sign I feel I feel so blessed thank you
so much for bringing me here like I am
so eye open and I feel like so sad that
I missed out on this beautiful Cuisine
all these years of my life until now
like what the hell I've been missing out
this is so delicious should we just
cheers with our dirty hands Cheers
Cheers Cheers we're definitely going to
keep eating but there's no stopping I
spy a sugar can juice so I have to try
it because I love sugarcan juice
hello do you put it on ice yeah
sometimes
some is it okay yeah that's good that's
good here we go let's try
it m how's so good very very good thank
it's delicious it's like it's it's
sugary but like not so sweet and it
actually has like a kind of like a
grassy
herbaceous note to it can't really get
this in the city like where do you get
fresh squeezed sugar can
juice yeah in a smoke shop all types of
[Music]
goodies hey guys it's Esther from heat
eaters thanks for watching please like
And subscribe and for more episodes
click here